- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is overcome your fears.
Over to you Gabrielle Bernstein.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- What's the first step
to overcoming the fear
or transforming the fear?
- To witness it.
To be the non-judgemental witness of it.
To look at it and say,
something's got to give.
So, if you're unwilling to
look at your fear head on
and honor it and witness,
I would say if you don't
show up for what's up, it
would it will keep showing up.
So looking at saying,
I witness my resistance
and you see that fear as resistance,
fear is the resistance to
what it is that you desire.
And in the absence of
resistance, you become a magnet
for what you desire, when
you let go of that fear
and you transcend that
fear, that's when you start
to become a super attractor.
That's when you start to let what is truly
of essence for you in your
life, what is truly of service
for you into your life,
what is true happiness
into your life and so looking at the fear,
witnessing it, calling it by its name,
and even if you don't have the tools yet,
what happens is when you look at the fear
and you're like oh, I see this
fear, I see this resistance,
I see how it's blocking
my life and I choose
to see it differently.
That's when you're listening
to an audio like this.
That's when a book like
yours will fall off a shelf.
- [Lewis] The catalyst.
- Yeah, exactly, you open up
your consciousness pretty much.
You crack open your
consciousness to find solutions
rather than fight problems.
So when you're not looking at the fear,
you're just living in the fear
and you're believing in the problem.
But when you witness the fear
and you're willing to see it differently,
you start living in the solution.
- I think the key to overcoming your fear
is the awareness of the fear.
I think most people aren't even aware
of their biggest fears
that are holding them back
on a daily basis in their
business and in their lives.
What often happens is somebody
gives you an opportunity.
Come speak at this event
or here's this project
to work with this person
or go on this date,
whatever it is, you get an opportunity,
and the real fear you have is
that you're not good enough.
That you're going to fail.
That you're not going
to give a good result.
That's really the fear deep down inside
when you come up with, I
don't have the time to do it.
I don't have the time to do
it is the biggest BS excuse
of all time.
You may not be making the
priority to go out and do it
but we all have the same amount of time.
You should never say
I don't have the time.
You can say I choose not to do it.
I choose not to make the time.
But as soon you say I don't have the time,
you abdicate responsibility.
You are in control.
You get to pick what you do
with your 24 hours everyday.
It's the one thing that is
equal across every human being.
We all have 24 hours.
So we disguise our real fear
with some practical reason.
We say we don't have the time,
we don't have the resources,
blah blah blah, whatever it is
but really it's some kind of fear.
And I think that's the
case for a lot of people.
So many of our fears are so subconscious
and we're so, we do it so automatically,
every single day and
we've convinced ourselves
there's a logical reason behind it.
So the first step in my mind
is the awareness of the fear.
The awareness that it's
not a lack of resources.
The awareness is not a lack of time.
And it's really that, I'm just afraid
that I'm going to fail and I
don't want to do it anymore.
So awareness of the
fear is the first thing.
Next thing is, do you have
to why to get out of it.
Is it important to break that thing?
Is it important to
crush through that fear?
Do you have a strong enough
reason to make a painful change?
And when you do, the third
step is to start to catch it.
And you often can't
catch it in the moment.
Usually comes afterwards,
usually if you're meeting
with somebody and you do the same thing
that you always do and you
don't catch it in the moment,
you catch it the next day.
Ah, I did it again, I
should have said that,
I should have done that and
I didn't, I did it again.
I succumbed to my fear again
and when you have that
awareness what you'll find is
the awareness is getting
closer and closer and closer
and closer to the moment
where it's actually happened.
So you started off and it's the
next day when you realize it
and then next time, maybe
a couple of hours later,
next time's a couple minutes later
and then you get to that magical moment,
that magical moment
where you caught yourself
just before you take the action.
You're meeting with somebody
and they're giving you
a project and you're bound to back away,
the words are about to
come out of your mouth,
it's about to happen
again, the same pattern
that you've always done forever and ever
it's about to come out again
and you had that magical moment
to catch yourself and choose to be bold
to overcome the fear to push through it
and take a separate action.
Instead of going the
same path you always go,
swerve and go this way.
And when you do that,
it gives you the muscle
to do it again.
And every time you get to that point,
it's going to become easier
and easier and easier
and easier and easier.
So one for me is understand
what your real fear is,
know that we have the awareness.
Two, have a strong enough
why to get out of it.
And then three, get closer
and closer and closer
to the moment to where it's happening
and then choose to be bold,
choose to be powerful,
and choose to push through your fear.
So the question of the day is, I'm curious
what is one of your biggest
fears as it relates to life
or business, not like a fear of snakes
but a biggest fear that
you have that you feel
is holding you back in
your business somehow,
leave down in the comments,
I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Paul Rogers.
Paul thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, really really
means a lot to me man,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- With every milestone,
while you might be excited
about the milestone, there's
a part of the milestone
that you don't want to
face, are you hearing me?
And listen to me, I've
knocked out the coursework,
boom, got it done, in order.
ET, why did it take you two years, ET,
after you finished your coursework
why did it take you two
years to get started
with your dissertation?
I'm going to be 100 with you,
look knocked all the coursework
out, but when I finally
got to the dissertation,
I had to get to that demon.
I had to deal with, I had
to face it, face what?
We're not talking about
elementary school, middle school,
high school, I've had a professor
or two tell me in college
that you will never get your dissertation,
that while your writing has improved
but in terms of your analysis,
like you are not critical
enough to do a dissertation.
Are you hearing what I'm telling you?
We're talking about, man I
love math coming up, why?
It is what it is, please
excuse my dear aunt Sally.
Like it is what it is right?
It's not subjective,
writing is subjective.
I've had teachers look at my work
and strip it into parts,
the fear, the fear of what,
the fear of rejection, right?
My teachers were so subjective,
I put my whole heart
into it, I put everything I could put
and they tell me, edit it
again, revision after revision.
Edit after edit, are you
hearing what I'm telling you?
I had to deal with the fact that writing
had never really been my strong suit
and even though I worked hard
and put in hours and hours
in the back mind, in the back of mind,
I could hear the teachers
say, ET you don't have
what it takes to get a dissertation.
I'm a grown man dealing with that fear.
I'm a grown man dealing with the rejection
of getting all that red on
my paper of having to do it
over and over and over and over
and come on, come on somebody feels me.
You'll feel like you'll do 120 percent,
you'll give everything you
have and it still won't
be enough, I feel you, I was there.
A part of the milestone is,
what if I give everything
and it ain't enough, what
if I put my whole heart,
my whole mind, my whole soul into it ET
and it's not enough, what
if I do it and I fail?
So I feel you, so you're just like you not
going to do it at all because
you'd rather not do it
and find out the truth and I'm telling you
you got to do me a favor,
you got to face your fear,
you got to do it anyway.
Your boy ET had to face
his fear, that's right,
I know you see ET, beast
mode, and you're right,
I am beast mode but it
don't mean beast mode
without fear, it don't mean beast mode
without a little anxiety.
It don't mean beast mode and
I'm just a 120 percent sure.
No, I have to live by faith
too and I made up in my mind,
ET, you got to go after it E.
Look I finished my coursework,
it took me two years, why?
'Cause it took me two
years to get over the fear.
It took me two years to
get over the anxiety.
It took me two years
to finally say, Goliath
here I come, Goliath, you
might be taller than me,
you might be bigger than me,
you might be stronger than me,
but I'm coming and I'd rather die trying.
I'd rather die going
after this dissertation.
I'd rather give everything I got,
I'd rather give a year, I'd
rather put in work and fail,
then not try at all.
- There's a scene in there
where you talked about
bullies and running from
danger and things like that
when you were trying to help this kid.
- Yeah, what happens is
this boy is being harassed
by the neighborhood bully
and his father's encouraging
his son to beat up this little boy.
And I wrote this scene, I
wrote this particular scene
in the script and I was trying to think,
what can I write to encourage this boy
to handle the situation,
you know with this bully
in the neighborhood?
And I'm spending days
trying to figure out,
what can I say to boy?
And finally I came up with the answer
and it was a situation that
I as a child had encountered
about his age, I went
to a school in Arizona
that was mostly Indians
from the reservation.
And there's this one Indian
kid who just didn't like me
and every day he chased
me home from school.
And I had to run by this gas station
and this mechanic watched me being chased
by this Indian kid every
day and finally he just
couldn't handle it
anymore and he stopped me
and made me face this boy.
And I told him, I said,
you know I'm scared.
And he said well, and what he said to me,
which is still true which
I remember is that he says
that running from your fear is
more painful than facing it.
And that's something
I've always remembered.
And this is what I relate to this boy.
And of course, eventually
he has to face this fear
in the film.